greetings ladies and gentlemen welcome
to another exciting episode of the
unittest radio hour I'm your Jedi host
Robert Stanley broadcasting live from
Palm Springs California on the greatest
alternative talk radio station on the
planet kg RA
thank you for tuning in always a
privilege and a pleasure today we have a
special guest who is also streaming
through his platform so let me introduce
Allen sake on he says he's the host of
simulation and he's in an interlocutor
I'm not sure what that means polymath
host of as I said host of simulation
which is it and you never heard of it is
a daily show on a live event serie
series featuring global leaders solving
humanity's most pressing challenges that
sounds very difficult let me tell you a
little bit more about Allen because I'm
still learning I'm still learning okay
we just met recently and he's hosted a
science comedy game show called Eureka
we I need to know more about this
because I'm actually hoping to host my
own gameshow someday I did okay
and that was in San Francisco and he's
also produced a two-day festival called
World's Fair Nano in New York City and
San Francisco so let's see he's in 2015
he decided to quit his nine-to-five job
and ask random people on the streets in
San Francisco thought-provoking
questions for a project called practice
happy that sounds really cool so
ultimately this is I think this is what
led into this current project called
simulation Allen's sake and welcome to
the program words family thank you so
much for having me I'm so excited for
this and huge shout out to Bill Skywatch
for helping us make this happen - yeah
Bill's the best I'm so lucky to have him
as my producer so okay tell us a little
bit more about what simulation is well
yeah okay I was gonna ask you what is
the ultimate nature of our reality first
but let's start with me and then we'll
get to all that yeah because I'm so
excited attempt to you about that
subject there's some planet Earth
there's a very interesting specimen
experiment happening yeah so yes so I
mean you got that really right yeah I
found myself being born in in Sioux
Falls South Dakota and
I noticed that the people around me for
some reason didn't have necessarily this
global drive to make some sort of
profound change and so I moved to
Silicon Valley and that's been seven
years ago I moved here and I've just
been I'm just connecting with different
leaders at the edge of their fields
everything from biotechnology neuro
technology AI and robotics spirituality
our science decentralization geopolitics
new economics every single field I'm
trying to dive deep into and talk to the
leaders in and then try and synthesize
what they know into some sort of a
relatable and educational piece for
other adults and kids on the planet so
they can gain a better understanding of
the ultimate nature of our reality and
right now I'm mostly doing it through
the show called simulation where I take
these different leaders and I bring them
on for one hour long interviews on our
show and we talk about their journeys
why why they're doing what they're doing
why it's important why it's building a
better future and we poke at them for
the ethical quandaries that exist around
these fields and we poke at them about
what's going on beyond the 3d reality in
the multi-dimensional hyper dimensional
spaces what's what's at play on planet
earth beyond us and we talk about that
we we poke a lot at people and augment
their perspectives these different
leaders and so yeah that's what we're
doing in yeah before that was a science
coyote show I was asking random people
on the streets question I was producing
that world's fair
so yeah just so really that's that's
that's that's a pretty good bit on on me
well there was one other piece and I
couldn't I came across it and I bought
market and I can't find it now you
apparently worked in Washington DC for a
period of time can you tell us about
that
Oh DC's interesting I spent a good chunk
of my high-school days as actually the
the president of the teenage Republicans
Club at my high school and then Wow yeah
and then I went to the you know teens
Republicans camp I helped several of the
candidates in the South Dakota House and
Senate with with running for their
positions as well as just local Sioux
Falls candidates as well and yeah and I
went to visit DC and I visited actually
also Tucker Carlson's recording studio
and stuff like that and and it was it
was interesting and I spoke with a
couple people that were a little bit
deeper in the state and it was it was
quite interesting seeing what was
happening there but I've kind of had
that political edge and just to just to
be clear and you know explain
I moved San Francisco so I went hyper
left and immediately once I noticed both
sides of the spectrum and I gained the
empathy from knowing both sides of the
spectrum I find myself in the center as
a centrist hyper driven by nuance by
multi variability by the art of really
good conversation steel Manning each
other's points and just trying to
synthesize from both fields into what
could be the best and so yeah so just to
give that a little bit of a background
to so people don't think that I'm clear
on one side you do not politically
polarized not whatsoever but since you
brought it up because I was kind of
curious how in European can we bring
both extremes sides of the party
so-called left and right wing what what
would be your best-case scenario
obviously a peaceful solution or
resolution to the to the current
conflict that's going on yeah but we
need a fantastic answer to interlocutors
to dialectics interviewers going back
and forth because we like asking
questions and so well you don't have to
answer right this minute let's just put
it this way if you or anybody else in
this audience has an idea even any idea
is better than nothing because the way
we're going right now especially with
the media seems to be constantly
promoting or hyping up the the the
differences or you call it the disputes
as opposed to the I mean here is it
their focus
the problem I never hear I'm talking
about the solution never or maybe I'm
missing something I don't even wanna
paint it close enough attention but it's
weird because people on the extreme left
ergo we know the answer we go just got
impeached robbed and people in the
residence and no just shut up and let us
build a wall or whatever it is I'm
oversimplifying up it's not they are so
not meeting in the middle here it's kind
of weird something that I think really
helps people come together is
understanding the origin of the species
because then they get and it's not just
the species but even our world and all
of the species on the planet the origin
story of the universe and the origin
story of life in general because when
when someone gets the origin story of
life then they get that we come from the
same source and when they come from the
same source the same mother the same
spirit that we all all life or has
arisen from then there's this deeper you
when you look at someone's eyes Robert
and everyone that's listening when
watching when you look at someone's eyes
really deeply for a long period of time
60 seconds or more than just in peace
looking at their eyes yeah get the
window directly into who they are their
essence their spirit their life and then
you really get how we come from that
same source that this person has it's
the word saunder they have their own
life experiences their own input stream
that's led them into having their family
their friends their co-workers people
online that they talk to their goals
their northstar their ambition in life
what they're pursuing and when we can
humble ourselves a little bit to see
that divine nature in each other and our
callings on this planet then we can
realize that we can more effectively
collaborate and compete and collaborate
and compete and work together and also
reharmonization discolors around the
planet or
saying that we got disconnected from and
that's why we have all ya issues that we
have in our civilization so that's
probably this main key for bringing
people together I think is when you re
harmonized with the divine nature of
life that there is something in the
first place instead of nothing and that
way you're experiencing this as avatars
and it's so beautiful as characters and
we can share this together in a more
abundant and prosperous way yeah instead
of a scarce way right yeah it's cut it's
I think too simplified it's the
difference is coming from a place of
love as opposed to a place of fear seems
and fear and anger and all the the dis
it's to be more specific I'd say
dissonance versus resonance one is
sustainable the other one is not and
unfortunately it seems like especially
in political arenas it's like the
dissonance is increasing which is not
good for you know these people are
supposedly representing our country it's
that's that's a dead end
ultimately so it's it's a huge problem
and I don't know that there's a simple
answer although that would be nice if we
could just get a simple answer and but
then implementing it you know these
people seem like they're really very
isolated and they you know again even
though they say there are duly elected
representatives they act like they are
Lords are over you know all of us and
and geez I don't know I don't know I
just it bothers me actually in another
really good question Robert is to ask
people is how would you redesign
civilization and okay when we ask that
question to each other we think well
what way could we rebuild our society to
maximize prosperity that every single
child that's born into the world should
have these basic nutrients if you
imagine them as a seed and they have the
root systems in the soil they need love
and compassion they need air they need
water they need food they need to
identify what their North Star is and
they need to
sooo that and so if any of those
nutrients are missing they're not gonna
have as many fruits in their tree and so
right want every child to have the
potential to have an abundant tree full
of fruits that they can share with
themselves their families their
communities society at large and so this
is one of the big aspects to the
synthesis that I'm working on is this
idea of the seed the seed theory how can
we do that more effectively okay so um I
don't know if you heard me talking or if
I actually sent you the link at the top
of my page you NICUs magazine.com the
website there's three three free books
called ami ami the friendly
extraterrestrial and it actually has the
blueprint in there for what a civilized
world how it operates and more
importantly how it's connected to other
civilized worlds through a fellowship in
peace and prosperity for everybody there
are no borders there's no government the
way we think of our governments for one
planet everybody lives his family it's
it's absolutely mind-boggling and
beautiful and and for some reason
there's a few people in this audience
that written to me say Robert I can't
find I don't know what's wrong I I'm
looking all over your website it's at
the top I I think it's so important now
I put the top of page at unicast my
magazine com you can't miss it I mean if
you do I don't understand why it's only
been a couple people actually but I'm a
little concerned because it's so obvious
when you go there to the top of my
homepage alright because I'm using that
I'm not just putting in a library or
whatever I'm putting I'm using my
homepage as a bulletin board since
there's a lot of space there instead of
just having the nav bar the nav bar at
the top I'm actually letting people see
my thought process I'm doing this on an
up I'm updating on a daily basis now
because there's just so much information
coming in and it seems to be all very
very positive been loving and
foundational in what the conversation
we're having now the work you're doing
I'm doing from different angles about
building a better future for everyone
and all living things that's really what
I'm excited about it
right totally yeah me too holy yes yes
and well hey we're you know we're all
blessed all right and I know it doesn't
always seem like it some days but even
the toughest moments in life are
actually very they're there in helping
us grow lessons and I yeah through life
lessons and overcoming these challenges
especially when we reach out to others
there was my favorite line in the movie
star man as he was getting ready to
leave and he was talking to that little
government employee and he said let me
tell you something the thing I love
about you guys is that you're at your
best when things are at their worst
so III really don't want to see bad
things happen but who knows maybe this
you know all the insanity that's going
on is going to lead to some sort of
breakthrough actually what I've always
said in my counseling was that in order
to have a breakthrough typically the way
we're set up we have to have a break
down literally it feels like I'm having
a breakdown well okay because the walls
are coming down and now you're starting
to really feel see and feel more and
yeah it hurts a little bit but you know
growth is like that growth is painful so
are our greatest treasures and same
thing with our okay that's an you that
like that these are little tests of
faith if you'll let me indulge for a
little bit on the trajectory so if
Robert Stanley has this life trajectory
and so he's he's going towards his North
Star and he's identifying a direction
over time with his life there are going
to be these bifurcating moments on the
trajectory and so the idea is that at
these moments to be extremely vigilant
and understanding is this a bifurcating
moment that's trying to suck my spirit
in and take me off of my North Star
trajectory or is this something that
maybe um maybe it's like one of the
negative ones could be something like an
it like an addiction to an exogenous
substance that I have to eat that I use
all the time now versus something versus
versus a a positive trajectory element
is something like if you take the advice
of a mentor
that's trusted that that gives you maybe
one of those little like short like a
hacker shortcut something that like
helps you achieve your Northstar faster
and so these things are it's a character
Robert what can you do to level up your
character towards your North Star as
fast as possible and how can your North
Star alignment be as the Nash
equilibrium as possible so that you're
both able to sustain yourself well and
not materialize yourself but sustain
yourself and your well-being well
meanwhile also providing with that
equilibrium to society you're providing
value with more society than you're
capturing from society yeah so some
level of reciprocity there yeah I
understand
and look everybody has that choice to
make you can you can't force people to
do it that's the other thing
that's why government I think in
religion is so ineffective in that
regard when it comes to society they
really both of those agencies kind of
fall short it looked the I'm not saying
they're completely flawed they could
just do a lot better and ultimately
again those books that suppose the
children's books what a what an
incredible message of love and and also
as you were saying a blueprint a divine
blueprint for for what is what is the
best possible of society what would it
look like and it's outlined in those
books again it's really just a summary
because you can't you can't explain
everything everybody about all that
stuff I think in fact it I don't think
that's even fair because you know those
are things that we will experience those
of us that want to experience going off
world and living a you know civilized as
civilized children of the cosmos or what
would be called you know part of the
fellow / Federation but it's not the
thing the thing one of the things that
we are really kind of I think is
blocking us is this whole concept of
millet type of domination
they call it nation-building but
actually typically
about destroying a nation or country and
then rebuilding it in your own image
alleged democracy we even know this is a
republic not to get all political on
people but I mean just saying that the
this thing is that we're doing right now
is unsustainable and I don't think going
to another world or worlds is going to
make it any better in fact I think it's
just going to complicate matters what do
you think yeah I mean a lot of the
indigenous wisdom is kind of like
shouting at all the people living in
Metropolis right metropolis is right now
like the kids being born can't see any
stars due to light pollution they walk
into grocery stores they've ever been to
a farm they've never put their hands in
the soil they think that a piece of
paper is exchanges for an apple and they
don't know how the Apple is grown now
these all these types of like the trade
that we're making for productivity to
build something like an infrastructure
of 5g technologies which again who are
we building these things for and how do
they longitudinally affect our health
our physiology our biology how do we
know these things that we're not slowing
down to think but we're just rushing
forward as quickly as possible so that
the economies the economy is and has now
become a machine that has no pause
button
there's no stop the economy day there's
everything is this is constantly roaring
and there's no it has no massive there's
not even a little rudder
there's no rudder at the back so you
can't even really make it on a more
positive trajectory but that's kind of
the role of the entrepreneur the artist
or the spiritual leader is to try and
move the rudder towards a more positive
trajectory I in the aspect of preserving
consciousness and moving it off the off
the rock to other rocks I everyone a lot
of people that I know are really a
pushing that that's an important part of
our future and it is an important part
of the future at the same time to untaek
spiritually graduate from third
rade first on planet earth is equivalent
ly important and probably even
prioritize that first graduate first and
then yeah here before we try to export
anything the problems to other rocks
yeah yeah and I believe that the books I
was telling you about the ami ami the
friend et friend that explains something
to me that I've been struggling with and
I know a lot of people in this field of
so called the New Age or alternative
stuff specifically about
extraterrestrials there's this narrative
that we have embraced about them being
evil or a threat and I mean that even
came up recently New York Times said oh
the Pentagon's investigating the threat
you know as if the Pentagon is not a
threat you know yeah so the problem is
that unless we actually like you said
become peaceful here now I don't think
we're getting off the planet there seems
to be a mechanism that's built into the
cosmos that prevents a virus like this
the insanity this negativity from
getting off world and then infecting
other worlds so it's I know a lot of
people are not going to be happy with
that because there we have all been
programmed to believe that you know
every all the other exit you know people
on other planets must be exactly like us
and I'm sure some of them are
uncivilized and militant like us but
they're either gonna blow themselves up
or they're never getting off that rock
either Furby peridot
where are they yeah yeah yeah all that
yeah and and so that's something that's
been largely overlooked for whatever
reason I kind of know what it is but I
don't want to belabor the point the the
prop the thing I'm one of focus though
on mom is this we already know what the
problem is unfortunately when we
externalize their own problems by saying
you know the devil maybe do it or it's
the reptilians or whatever you know that
is not going to resolve our in our
imbalance typically is isn't is pretty
simple though I mean really
much love do you have how much resonance
are you willing to generate or embrace
in your life love those two words that
you came back to love and resonance the
more that we can bring that forth from
within ourselves and then around our
families and our communities and our
society the more that we can bring that
that feeling that energy forth then we
don't then we don't need to sit and go
I'm being controlled right now and yeah
defeatist attitude can I do want to ask
you though Robert okay I want to ask you
this question what is the ultimate
nature of our reality here on planet
earth well I'm still thinking about
because might not a here's that here's
reason and I'll answer the question the
best of my ability but I just want to
say as a caveat that I'm still trying to
figure that out myself and it should be
self-evident honestly everybody should
know the foundation or the origins as
you're as you're talking about here of
our true nature not just our true nature
but the nature of the cosmos and it
seems like that like everything else
here we have all these competing
theories or narratives or whatever about
what it is how it came into be and what
our role is in it ultimately so I don't
think there's a simple answer to that
balint you had asked me yeah what's the
nature of this reality
yes apparently because we okay so my
understanding at this point just just to
be clear is that because it's
multi-dimensional the this particular
realm that we're in typically is an
illusion I I think you know the Hindus
had it right when they called it Maya
or an illusion because as what do you
call a well not quantum physics it just
shows that everything that we think is
solid isn't and that so therefore right
there is one level of the illusion the
other thing is that we also in I think
we are living an illusion in the sense
that that there's everything so-called
inanimate objects are not only solid but
they have zero consciousness which is
not true
because consciousness is waves and when
you look at the particle even a
so-called solid matter
it really is waves as well so there's
different levels of consciousness for
sure
you know as it was described to me is
consciousness it's one level of wave
form then you have energy it's a
slightly lower wave form and then you
have matter but they're all wave forms
and they're all interrelated I think the
bigger question is what is generating
all these wave forms throughout creation
and and and at that point I would have
to you know to kind of default back to
the soul or souls that were created like
you said these seeds
I call them seeds of light or some
people call God seeds or whatever but
they look we look like seeds of light in
a garden of light that's interconnected
through a web of light that was all
divinely and intelligently created to
support life which means consciousness
so it's like the this is one of the the
key components that um science currently
does not want to address I don't think
that most of most of them are doing that
fact that everything is conscious
conscious or of consciousness that it is
spirit that ultimately moves down into
the lower frequencies of matter and and
and then ultimately returns back to the
higher frequency it's constantly cycling
through but we know through the
entanglement right quantum entanglement
everything is connected but like the way
we showed to me one of my contacts out
there in Malibu in the mountains was
that everything is really connected
through this web of light including us
the weird part is we can choose to
disconnect somehow somehow that's an
option because of freewill and when when
we do that typically we suffer we don't
have the same level of awareness or
abilities that would that normally come
with having that level of connectivity
to the all of creation I hope that
answers your question yeah you took us
on a
terrible trajectory there so all also
all also hit it from another perspective
that's super aligned with that is that
we were talking about source earlier in
the conversation what what is creation
in the first place what started this Big
Bang in this universe as well as
potentially all these other parallel
running universes that are potentially
housing different forms of consciousness
these different forms of life - why why
why and it's seen as though this is a
massive artistic expression of God of
creation of source and that especially
planet Earth
is hilariously beautiful because it is
the one of the only places that you can
be birthed and so that you are under the
illusion that you are separate from
creation and so when and so that's the
idea is that when you're born that the
first thing you got to do is and this is
one of the massive most massive problems
on the planet is that children aren't
informed that they're part of source and
so that's the first thing is remember
that you are source you are creation
that we are all nerve endings of
creation feeling artistically expressing
ourselves and then the second thing that
the kids need is to know their North
Star and so that they have to figure out
what is their unique expression of their
own artistic capacity on this rock and
so um and then now would you get it a
little bit deeper in the space I'm still
starting to you know learn about it
mostly through people like Bernard
Gunter and Tom Montauk are the people
that I'm most following in the space I'm
trying to follow more people in it but
what about what about beyond you know ok
creation happened and then the idea is
that ok why is it that there it seems to
be that this is a big chessboard for
light and dark forces and why does it
seem land who's in control of what what
what are these controls beyond the
actual physical planet and then what is
actually go
on on the surface through humans and
were like channels and then there's
different power structures that are
happening and it's it's supposed to be
that's why this book that you're talking
about is again one of these ideas of
like this uh what could be what could be
this pinnacle civilization and I love
that idea and there's always room for
like mathematic parallax to continue
building a better and better world this
is not a finale right but then the other
notion is that well is isn't the
artistic expression beautiful the way it
is with the exact amount of light and
dark good and bad that's on here playing
because then we actually have the beauty
of there's a struggle still that we have
to figure our selves out this type of
thing well if this is really nursery for
seeds of light you know when you plant a
seed two paths that go into the soil
which is dark and it has to struggle
towards the light and so and as it as it
does that it becomes stronger and
stronger and as to now it has to endure
other challenges like whatever so you
know yeah but I mean it's organic see
this is the thing about it we tend to
especially in this culture we tend to
look at things very synthetically and
including ourselves and I feel that's a
huge disservice that we're doing to our
divine nature the you know somehow we
look down on it like nature is something
that we need to dominate or exploit when
in fact we're part of that and the more
closely that we harmonize with it and
respect it the better it is because that
is a level of reciprocity and again if
it's all based on consciousness there's
going to be this feedback mechanism that
comes to us in a very positive way if we
put it out positively then it's going to
come back I mean that's just not that's
just so obvious but again you say if you
started a child in a culture like that
then surely their path forward would be
it's just like having seeds in a garden
if you yes if you let all the weeds go
and there's rocks in the soil and
there's no nutrients and it's just like
whoa they're gonna be like dwarf and
mutants and maybe they'll get somewhere
but no but if you
the soil you and you give it nutrients
and all the water and and even love you
know I was asking a friend recently
because I say when in Hong Kong you know
it's like why are the Japanese fruits so
expensive
and so delicious and it was actually my
my my friend's son he was he's been
living there it was part of an exchange
program he's actually living there
working in Japan and he said they they
love their the plants yeah this is the
for one fruit they may even just and
they'll sing to the tree you know I know
they bring it to nutrients and they're
just so happy that this tree is alive
and it's gonna it's going to give them
this gift of the it's fruit and they
it's like the you think you know just an
apple you think I was just an apple whoa
you cut it open it's like my god I've
never smelled an Apple like that or
tasted anything like it and it's it's
just that's you know that's how we can
be that's how we are we're just like
that fruit mmm I love it Robert that's
so good yeah the what we can do for
remembering what nourishes us each
breath of air each sip of water each
bite of food is literally us being
nourished by source and when we remember
that and we fully embody that work more
connected on a moment-to-moment breath
by breath even basis and your example is
so beautiful there's all these other
examples that have been happening around
the world where people are seeing to
patients as well and they're on their
spirit they're calling they're calling
the clearance of certain diseases
they're calling the all types of health
care augmentations all these types of
things the growing the food on the tree
in the garden and like your example to
we're so we got to remember here's a
really good way to put it - Robert if
we're only just such a minut percentage
even point percentage difference
from our evolved ancestors right doesn't
it sometimes feel like we're crickets
trying to imagine the big game we're
trying to imagine the big game right the
big game of creation yeah as crickets
and so and so we got to do our best to
envision what that big game is and I
actually think you know part of the
reason why the show is called simulation
for all those tuning in you can find
it's simulation series.com is where you
can find it or on youtube simulation
series the idea behind it one of the
reasons is that once a civilization of
consciousness becomes has enough
computational capacity and you can you
you hear about it all the time now with
this word digital twin you can make a
digital twin of Robin Stanley and see
all of his biometrics happening and add
a specific action to his body and see
how it affects him before you do it to
the actual physical one
you can make a digital twin over the
civilization so that general idea is
that if you can run a simulation of a
civilization and you literally press the
start button this is like the creation
right this is like we're talking yes
artistic expression unleash it you can
just like when you edit video for those
are time lapses for those that know what
that's like you can take a 13.8 billion
year period and I can literally just
click and drag through the 13.8 billion
year period as I please right and then I
can watch play what happens and then
fast-forward five hundred years watch
the evolution of fire and language and
an art and religion and and books and
and all different types of
civilizational tools processes and then
you gain so much insight from thinking
about things in that way you get this
we're talking about being the crickets
and thinking about the big game well
then you get the perspective of the big
game when you do stuff like that when
you run these thought experiments to
talk to your friends and other people
about these thought experiments yeah it
sounds very similar to what they say the
Akashic record that there's some sort of
way that you can scroll through that and
it's not just a simulation when like I
know it's not artificial life sugar
escape was the first one that they did
like this so there's it here's the thing
that you have
ants in in a program and you have very
simple rules the red ants and the black
ants are competing for digital sugar and
and the funny thing is as simple as that
is every time they ran the program it
was a slightly different permutation
would come up and I believe that's
that's kind of how we are it it just in
there's so many potentialities that we
can't really say for sure what it is but
we have a kind of a general idea of how
things will happen but they don't you
know they it's and there's no guarantees
and I'm pretty sure that this is again
this is part of the rule in the
background of this particular if you
want to call it a simulation is is that
there is a the- there is there's a- like
a parasitic like a gnat have that that
if we do not have enough or as you say
when we do not have enough love that
means that that we we have some level of
negativity in our hearts that's when the
these parasites actually have it's like
it gives them something to latch on to
it's a signal that they can then hack
into and ultimately control us for their
benefit and there's that but the
ultimate benefit of all that is you if
our negativity gets so much higher than
our love v fear overcomes the love then
the system collapses you know it just
and it does but the thing is it'll reset
that's the other cool thing about it is
that there's constant this constant
reset that's why I'm not sure that the
Big Bang is is accurate it's possible
that there was just a reset because we
you know time as we know it is is
relative it probably doesn't exist or or
have any relevance whatsoever to the
bigger picture so it's it's an
assumption that's why I call it the Big
Bang Theory it's not been proven it
makes sense to us but that doesn't mean
that it's really it's real or accurate
so we've got a lot to learn I'm sure and
thank goodness we there's a lot to learn
because if we had it all figured out
that would be
that would be the end of the game or the
show I would be over I suppose every
time if we don't have love that we're
deeply connected to within our essence
and we're sharing that around the world
and our communities our families etc
we're giving space for fear for other
parasite to come through us and then
that immediately cascades as a butterfly
effect around us as well ah yeah yeah
yeah I remember that the chaos
complexity the butterfly sneezes in the
bush you know the whole it's like yeah
well that's again about entanglement
everything is connected to everything
else it's so that's why we it says I'll
just be loving well guess what when you
do that it's because we're connected to
everything else it does resonate out the
more resonance or love that you have it
goes out into the creation so it's not a
small thing when you are being when you
are feeling and sharing love it actually
is it is the antidote it is the ansan
it's you know it is and Robert another
really great way of putting it is that
if it just watch one example for
everyone just watch what happens when
you go for a full day of smiling like
wide smile wide with enthusiasm
everywhere you go and lock deeply with
other people in eye contact during that
smile you'll see is such a big shift in
other people's days by seeing your
ecstatic smiling and so yeah it's
contagious yes yeah and then they go on
to their families with a bigger smile
and their communities and so this is
this is and and this is not coming from
someone that's perfect that always does
it themselves this is someone that's
right right we're always learning and
we're creatures that are that are
constantly iterating on our on our on
our on how to align ourselves most
divinely with our with our North Stars
but that is such a big one Robert love
and spreading that around you on a
moment-to-moment basis and
but yeah really no not not just
intellectualizing it Robert we have such
a big problem with people that
intellectualize things in our world I
yeah I'm you know just talking to mama
Luigi Wanda the Kogi elder from Colombia
one of these indigenous wisdoms that are
that are coming through these tribes
that are coming through and saying these
things I mean they're so clear about it
it's just in the head everything's in
the head I get it I understand
uh III and then and then verse is when
like literally just zip silence your
mouth close your eyes it's happened and
reconnect to your self reconnect to your
heart tap into your body and tap into
this channel of divinity what is your
North Star reflect on that process more
talk to your friends about their North
Stars find other young people and older
people that have connected their North
Stars and learn from them and that
process and you can see it nature is the
best teacher you can see the divinity in
nature on a moment-to-moment basis it's
oozing love sure like I said it's a web
of light and you want to connect it when
we choose to connect to it it gives us
all kinds of nutrients or information or
I look at it this way just to be simple
trying to simplify it if you want to be
healthier and happier and smarter and
stronger increase the love quotient in
your heart by whatever means works for
you okay I mean I'm just saying I know
it works I'm doing it myself and I'm
sharing that's one of the reasons I'm so
adamant about sharing those ami books
with people but I was looking at
Celestine Prophecy last night sort of
like I would I do this with books
sometimes like a magic 8-ball you know
you got to shake it up and then you the
look and see what is your what is the
answer well I just I this how it is I
just open I just crack open a book and
see if there's there's a message in
there well because I've been focusing on
this whole thing about love and creation
or God and so father Sanchez says to
whatever the character's name in
Celestine Prophecy
I know it's it's rich James Redfield
wrote this but he said the father
Sanchez
he defined what love is and is not and
this I thought was very very instructive
give he is it's love is not an
intellectual concept which we were
talking about before about thinking too
much well it's it's not an intellectual
concept or a moral imperative or
anything else it is a background emotion
that exists when one is connected to the
energy available in the universe which
of course is the energy of God which is
love and how my god that's so good
I know I got the chills let's look at I
go okay thank you thank you magic 8-ball
you know it's like it's crazy because
again if I if I open myself to the idea
or the reality that we're just
describing here that it everything is
consciousness then I'm going to I'm
gonna get these downloads I'm open
because I'm open closed and that's
actually that's how I get been able to
get so much information in a relatively
short time in this in this life just by
opening myself up and more importantly
sharing it with others instead of just
hanging onto it going on you know who
cares about everybody else part of the
agreement part of my relationship with
creation is a you you want to give it to
me I'll just pass it on to other people
because I know that that are interested
it's gonna help them to and in that
regard it'll kind of everybody's gonna
you know raise their the whether they
say rising tide lifts all boats
that's very beautifully said that love
is not the intellectual love is this
background emotion that exists and the
love is and here's another word
potentially for the listeners and
viewers right now is pantheism pantheism
everything is part of an
all-encompassing imminent God universe
and God are identical all forms of
reality may then be considered either
modes of that being and so you know this
is again this is God is not behind
nature God is nature pan pantheism all
all is God all is God so all is love and
and there's other there's other like we
were talking a little bit about paying
psychism everything is a conscious
animism is another one everything
animism here it yep that one is another
one another good one
I think this is another good one
actually for people from what we were
mentioning at the beginning part where
you're super polarized versus more
synthesizing is um is two dots
eclecticism which is very much so like a
polymath you draw upon multiple theory
styles or ideas to gain complimentary
insights into a subject yeah it comes
from Greek that's what a polymath is all
ya polymath like having learned much and
that it comes out of Greek neglect eCos
literally choosing the best and
syncretism comes from sink rhesus
combining of different beliefs blending
schools of thought merging assimilating
certain discrete fields or trend
traditions like theology and mythology
of religion asserting underlying unity
allowing occlusive approaches to other
face this type of things a syncretic
politics would work here for what we
were talking about so um yeah yeah yeah
oh the other thing we were talking about
too is I forgot the other component
about when we go into this mode of the
threat the it's always the external
enemy is that in especially in this
world I can't deal with the external
enemy so I'm looking for an external
Savior and and that is a recipe for
disaster every freaking time that
doesn't work it absolutely doesn't work
it's just uh
and it advocate basically abdicates any
reason Allah tea for one's well-being
and especially the love quotient that
they're feeling it's just like you just
completely given up if you're the cap in
a ship yours like AI don't want to steer
anymore you guys and it's crazy it
really is crazy you you're rocking it
there I love how you keep using the
words love quotient I love that one and
then on to reflect on that when we wake
up in the morning and go to bed at night
instead of immediately grabbing our
phones but please just reflect on our
death quotient that one and then and
then you you are also mentioning like we
got to remember that everything that we
need is
endogenously found within us it's bound
within us our North Star our
actualization in this world and our
gifts that we can bring other people is
found within us and so anytime we're
looking for exogenously to actualize
it's already a recipe for disaster
mmm yeah so role politicians and priests
play anyway boom is that they're
supposedly some they're in a position
today in fact they're probably screwing
it up yeah there's so much self-dealing
that happened a good part that crazy
that's all it's mostly something good
part has evolved in those categories
it's so much less about actually
inclusive global fitness and it's way
more about just how can I deal myself
quickly and then get out of the equation
if they're self dealing propaganda in
food companies there's fake food there's
fake news there's fake physicians
happening there's fake teaching
happening and so it's so important to be
very vigilant with the input stream that
we consume be very vigilant with what we
put in our bodies we get too much they
don't ask you one this is an easier
question what is the most beautiful
thing in the world that's well it's love
obviously but I think that's a very
objective no excuse me subjective
question because to me all right let's
put it this way the most beautiful sound
is a baby laughing I think the most ugly
sound is a baby crying and it's it's
they're just so but it's coming from the
same source and it's just like one is
this one is dissonance one is distress
the other one is joy and love and
resonance so it's anyway it's it's all
it's that the cool thing is that we have
an incredible potential here to tap into
in the future and that's what I'm
looking forward to